keukenhof near amsterdam has the biggest
display of tulips in the world the park
opens every year just before spring to
display a rainbow of tulips in every
color imaginable this is also where
people come to gain inspiration for
their own spring gardens Gabriella Papa
advises people about what's best for
their gardens as the spring season gets
underway not effective rulings gotten
there me the perfect spring garden is
one that's an bloons where the snowdrop
season is over and the daffodils are
starting to blossom then the tulips and
the crocuses where you can really see
what the season has to offer bust
Jesus's on to beatin that gabriella Papa
has owned and managed the Royal Garden
Academy in Berlin since 2008 but don't
be fooled by the name it's a nursery
open to the public and a place where
amateur gardeners can come to find the
perfect plants for their plots alongside
a cafe and restaurant several
greenhouses serve as a smorgasbord of
flower arrangements Papa likes to be
hands-on and often helps her customers
pick out the best combinations
man Matt dose ohana got over you can
really tell from the fashions to there
are a lot of primary colors big colors
pastels aren't in any more but real
oranges real Reds bright colors this
year's colors are very affirmative sir
beyond do farm DS yet urban gardening
has taken off over the past few years as
more and more people choose the city
over the country Stefan faust row who
lives in a trendy district of Berlin
likes to escape hectic city life on his
rooftop terrace gardening helps with got
none be daughter Devin basically
gardening means that the weather is
improving we can go out again it's
getting greener warmer and for us with
our terrorists it means we get an extra
room before moving here Stefan spent 15
years in an apartment with no terrace or
balcony so for ham gardening is a
newfound passion he's always on the
lookout for new ideas Mincy cement has
become very fashionable before nobody
here would have thought of planning it
but everyone has it now for cocktails or
mint tea
those who need a little more assistance
in planning a garden can turn to
Gabriella Papa for design ideas as well
as layout she spends much of her time
helping people gree create the landscape
surrounding their homes the result is a
stunning contrast to the original
but Papa is really in her element when
she's outside interacting with her
customers and helping them decide what
to plant in the end though the perfect
garden boils down to one's own personal
taste among curds and butter cups are
important and horn violets are very
pretty oops tell people I do the heavy
work as a skinny now I'm clinton and
ikea I don't follow fashions as a second
wife I just say I want to bring greenery
to my Terrace so I get plants that stay
green all year round buses can see
ugliness your we gonna zone I think if
you're starting a new garden you need a
good mix and plenty of shrubs as they
bring a lot of pleasure very quickly so
not just annuals and not so many bushes
as they need a lot of time mosey along
about and what's in and out for two
thousand sixteen thousand is moment
these many lawns are not so popular at
the moment people prefer grass with
flowers in order to encourage bees fruit
bushes are totally in oops whereas
plants often used on motorways like
cotoneaster czar completely out so are
bigger bushes all these terrible ground
cover plants its board and decoders our
first delegates are the perfect spring
garden is also about timing so don't
beat around the bush make hay while the
Sun begins to shine
hey do what you wanna do